well now then the big question that fans  of The Today Show have been asking who  won't replace Kathie Lee Gifford when  she leaves in April well now we know  [Music]  Jenna gets the gig Kathie Lee made the  official announcement this morning what  did your mom and dad see my dad just  wrote me three words which made me weep  he said very proud she fits I mean it's  like one big family  and I think we all feel that and then  novice at red carpets we first met Jenna  back in 2007 she joined the Today Show  in 2009 and we were with her a few  months later as she covered the 2010  Winter Olympics in Vancouver I'm still  working for the Today Show the two weeks  that you guys were off at the Olympics  I saw you blossom whom you'd earned the  right to sit and be something to all  these wonderful people that watch us  every day Kathie Lee will officially  pass her wine glass over to Jenna on  able to fifth  [Music]